même lorsqu'il reçoit l'émir du qatar
c'est l'ukraine qui revient sur la table
joe biden est interrogé sur la question
à chaque sortie et son administration
continue de mettre la pression
diplomatique sur la russie pour la
dissuader de toute invasion dernière
accusation date celle de l'ambassadrice
américaine à l'onu
la russie a déplacé près de 5000 salle
d'arts mielleux russie avec des missiles
balistiques à courte portée des forces
spéciales et des batteries entier rien
nous avons vu des preuves que la russie
à l'intention d'augmenter sa présence à
plus de trente mille soldats près de la
frontière entre la biélorussie et
l'ukraine à moins de deux heures au nord
de kiev d'ici début février
les partenaires occidentaux de
washington poursuivrait aussi cette
politique de pression contre moscou
emmanuel macron s'est entretenu avec
vladimir poutine pour la deuxième fois
en quatre jours au moment même où la
france tenté de se faire entendre au
conseil de sécurité de l'onu aussi on de
sphères d'influencé
n'a pas sa place au 21e siècle
si la russie ne choisit pas la voie du
dialogue et du respect du droit
international la réponse sera forte et
unie machenaud occidentaux parlent de la
nécessité d'une désescalade cependant il
7-6 a vendu à eux mêmes les tensions et
la rhétorique ce sont eux qui provoque
l'escaladent vous appelez presque à ce
que cela arrive vous voulez que ça se
produise vous attendez que cela se
produise comme si vous vouliez que vos
mots deviennent une réalité
la demir poutine réclament des garanties
de sécurité pour son pays et persiste
dans son refus de tout élargissement de
l'otan à des pays d'europe de l'est et
notamment l'ukraine une demande toujours
rejetée par les occidentaux même si
l'adhésion de l'ukraine n'est pas à
l'ordre du jour